they come to calais from all over the
world those desperate to reach britain
and to start a new life
it is these people who often rely on
smugglers and flimsy boats to get them
across the channel
and who are now threatened with being
sent to rwanda
we meet sharif and his family
their son is 18 months old he spent his
whole life as a refugee
sharif says the rwanda policy won't
deter him because he's got nothing to
lose so i know
government for uk
you send
people
rwanda
but
[Music]
i don't have nothing for my hand you
know
at this charity they help migrants
living along this stretch of the french
coast with foods clothes and support
the volunteers here don't like the
rwanda policy but they also think it
won't work that it will simply empower
people's smugglers even more these
people these refugees are not going to
want to claim asylum in the uk anymore
because of the threat they're going to
be forced underground which actually
does the opposite to the people
smugglers it increases their business
model
already this year the number of migrant
crossings is up
few expect it to now suddenly decline
well on a clear day like this you can
make out the kent coastline through the
haze it's perfect conditions for anyone
who wants to try to cross the channel in
a flimsy boat and thousands of those
journeys have started from here song
beach over the years that's the
challenge for this government policy
will it really deter
anyone who is determined to get from
here
to there
it is a perilous crossing last year on
this same stretch of beach we saw
overcrowded boats
entire families putting their lives at
risk
the reality is that once you've traveled
from iraq syria afghanistan and go all
the way to this beach with dreams of
starting a new life in britain the
finishing line really does feel
tantalizingly perhaps irresistibly close
adam parsons sky news calais